we're just days away from Sofia
Vergara's wedding to Joe Manganiello and
et has a scoop on how she's preparing
for the big day I don't think she's
really nervous I think she's excited and
she teases that she's become bridezilla
but I haven't seen it in any capacity
she seems to be handling it beautifully
dr. Dundee Engelmann is behind Sofia's
glowing skin
she tells ET the bride began beauty
preps two months ago but they kicked up
the treatments a week out we've treated
Sophia with the oxy light facial that my
aesthetician a DJ does and it is amazing
and so therefore you can step right out
of this room and walk right down the
aisle a little-known fact
Sophia actually has sensitive skin and
so she tends to flush a little bit so I
recommend SkinCeuticals phyto corrective
gel which helps to neutralize the
redness and calm down the flushing or
blushing bride and day of Sophia is very
protective of her skin despite being of
Colombian descent and she uses a
self-tanner called Vita Liberata which
is a tanning mousse and that's her
absolute favorite and then just a body
shimmer by Moroccan oil which will help
give a beautiful glow to her body and
she's ready to walk down the aisle
beside that glow all eyes will be on
Sophia's custom Zuhair Murad gown dr.
Engelman gives us a hint of what we
can't expect so you obviously wants her
figure on the red carpet so I think it
will probably see a little bit of that
with the decollete and the back exposed
but she's beautiful shoulders and check
Janet's some of the prettiest hands I've
ever seen so just how much will this fab
skin treatment cost of Sophia not
counting possible multiple sessions
we're talking approximately two thousand
at three hundred and three dollars the
answer when you say what does it cost to
view celebrity is a lot and so people
who are invested in their appearance
frequently will invest a lot in it not
that she needs to but it certainly is
not
you know without without a price